[Music]
this is an economic surveyor he's doing
something kind of radical well for back
then
he's not asking her about her finances
he's asking her how she feels about her
finances
he's surveying for the consumer
sentiment index one of two main
measurements of consumer confidence
consumer confidence is very low consumer
confidence how people feel about the
strength of the economy now and in the
future
here's how it became an important
indicator and why the federal reserve
thinks it's the key to bringing down
inflation
consumer confidence is different from
other measurements because the man who
created the first survey dr george
cadona wasn't just an economist he was
also a psychologist he began surveying
consumers in 1946 before that according
to his book economic surveys were all
about asking people what their changes
in income were numbers but he thought it
would be important to know how people
felt about their personal finances and
the changes they expected you have all
these economists walking around with all
their spreadsheets and all their numbers
you know you have these fed officials
getting up there and speaking a language
nobody really understands and then at
the end of the day so much of all this
comes down to feelings to me economics
is a social science i am also one of
those folks that's running around with a
clipboard and and looking at
spreadsheets dr joanne shu is katona's
successor at the university of michigan
where she oversees the survey for the
consumer sentiment index i have always
been really interested in how people
make economic decisions and what better
way to learn about that than just ask
people the survey conducted by calling a
nationally representative sample of
people on their cell phones asks five
questions that are nearly identical to
the five asked 70 years ago compared to
a year ago financially are you better
off or worse off what do you expect a
year from now in a year what do you
think business conditions will be
in the next five years do you expect
continuous good times or unemployment
and depression and when it comes to
major household appliances is now a good
time or a bad time to buy we want to
make sure that our questions are are
timeless and are not really
specific to the 60s specific to the
2000s the five questions are calculated
into the consumer sentiment index the
higher the number the better consumers
are feeling the lower the number the
worse they feel and it's a pretty
reliable indicator if you look at our
consumer sentiment measure and you look
at gdp growth you can see that consumers
actually do a really good job
anticipating changes in gdp a majority
of gdp is consumer spending so what
better way to understand where gdp is
going and then to understand um how
consumers are behaving in the 1960s as
consumer confidence began to be regarded
as an important measure another survey
began appropriately named the consumer
confidence index run by the conference
board
you can see the results are pretty
similar to each other but their
questions are slightly different
the conference board asks more about
your job like do you think there will be
more or less jobs in your area in six
months
so their index is more receptive to
consumers feelings around the job market
while michigan's index is more receptive
to inflation you can see the difference
in the 2008 recession as people lost
their jobs the confidence index dropped
more than the sentiment index if you
focus more on labor markets you're going
to have higher levels of confidence if
people are focusing more on inflation
that's something that will show up um on
our data in 2022 that is showing up and
what we're discovering now with these
falling sentiment numbers is that even
though the job market is really strong
and unemployment is really low
americans are very frustrated and
pessimistic because of the inflation
they're experiencing and these indexes
have become leading indicators because
they both indicate recessions often when
they begin to drop a recession follows
well except for this blip here in 2011.
it was not followed by a recession
sentiment was extremely low because of
the debt ceiling negotiations and that
was a factor that was lifted very
quickly but the drop in sentiment in
2022 has economists worried it's why the
federal reserve is very focused on
convincing people and why you hear
people like jay powell say he's going to
get this under control because he
doesn't want people to start thinking
that inflation is here to stay we think
that the public generally sees us as as
very likely to be successful in getting
inflation
down to two percent and that's critical
it's absolutely key to the whole thing
there is definitely a potential for self
fulfillment when it comes to inflation
the specific way this typically happens
if people believe that inflation is
going to get worse they might start
stockpiling and buying more now if they
believe prices are going to go up in the
future and if they front load their
consumption and bring their future
consumption into the present that is an
increase in demand and that will
increase prices by itself it's why the
federal reserve doesn't just need to
lower inflation chairman powell needs
the public to feel confident that they
will jay powell is playing a mind game
right now he's out there to convince not
only the public but the markets that
he's not going to allow this thing to
get worse and that he's going to get it
under control the confidence indexes
can't make consumers more confident but
at least they provide a measurement of
how they're feeling consumers workers
are the backbone of the economy
understanding their intentions and and
their
and their experiences in the economy
tells us a lot for the trajectory of the
economy thanks to a psychologist who
understood that behind all these
economic numbers are people
[Music]